What kind of games and things do you play with them and make up with them?
I have an elaborate... it's a lexicon of games that I have invented.
One of 'em is called "The Choo Choo Coming Through," which is you kinda sit on a chair...
...and they crawl under your legs and you stop them before they get out and ask them a question.
And they have to answer the question. Then if they answer the question, you go, "OK, go ahead."
I mean obviously, kids like grown-ups, sadly, are very amused by body function...
...references of any kind.
You know, two kids were in my closet...
...last night naked and they were sitting on my garment bag.
And I said, "Don't get your butt crack juice on my garment bag!"
Now I don't know, I just made that up, you know.
I don't know what butt crack juice is.
But I knew butt, you know, anything with butt, crack, you know,...
...it's gonna get a big laugh, you know. And of course they fell over, you know.
What is the game called "Fly Over the Bath"?
"Fly Over the Bath" is...
...one kid is in the bath and he has a little squeeze toy that fills,...
...you can fill it up with water...
...and the other kid, I fly them over the bath.
And as the one kid flies over, the kid in the bath squirts...
...the other kid in the face...
...with the water.
And then there's another one called "Jump Up,"...
...which is I lie one kid on the edge of the bed...
...and they stay there and then the other kid, I throw the other kid over.
And I tell the one lying on the bed, "In one minute..."
"...you're gonna see a little kid dressed in pink, is gonna come flying right over your face."
"So just watch out for that."
It's just , you know, silliness.